We can write two ratios and set up a proportion. We can set them equal to each
other. I know that for 3 packs of gum, I have to pay 87 cents. For 10 packs of
gum, I don't know the cost. I'm going to use a variable to represent that
number, I'm going to use t. We have one equation and one unknown. So, let's
solve for this variable. We multiply both sides of the equation by the
denominators. 87 hundredths times t. The 87 hundredth is reduce to 1, because
they are a factor in the numerator and the denominator, and the t is reduce to
1. t divided by t, makes 1. So, I'm left with 3 times t on the left, or 3t, And
8 and 7 tenths on the right, the result of 10 times 87 hundredths. Remember, we
just move the decimal one place to the right. I know t represents an amount of
money, so I know 8 and 7 tenths is really 8 dollars and 70 cents. I going to
divide that amount by 3, so 1t is equal to $2.90, this was the cost of our ten
pack of gum. If you've gotten at least one of these right, nice work. We're
going to solve similar problems involving expressions and equations in the next
sections. Keep up the great work.